[Musique]
le beau temps devrait être là ce week
end et mélanie pour notre rendez-vous
juniors vous avez justement choisi de
nous emmener faire une activité
extérieure
est-ce que ça dimanche câline c'est la
17e fête des fermes dans la vallée de
chevreuse une journée complète pour
aller à la rencontre des producteurs
éleveurs et agriculteurs ni parc naturel
une journée à vivre en famille au grand
nombre d'activités concerne des enfants
et cette année trois fermes participent
à l'événement dont la ferme de
grandmaison à chevreuse ça ce même 10
ans que martin et frédéric blin leurs
portes de leur élevage ce sont des
éleveurs de bovins des blondes
d'aquitaine plus précisément ils ont
près de 500 bovins avec environ 160
naissances par an il pèse
il possède aussi 60 brebis et 110
agneaux et 50 poule de ponte pour les
oeufs alors pour cette édition il
propose plusieurs animations écouter
passant sous le pont de l'âne les
chevaux
on a prévu une animation tout d'abord
avec un maréchal ferrant qui va nous
expliquer le faire devant nous avec la
forge un fer à cheval
il y aura donc un spectacle à cheval
donc ce thème le western avec un typique
une insulte dans la prairie derrière moi
donc plusieurs chevaux où on pouvoir
donc par ce spectacle et les enfants
m'ont est installée de le tout autour de
2,7 prévus qui est donc clôturé en tout
pour assurer la sécurité des enfants et
il y aura aussi une balade à poney
accompagner une des balades en tracteur
faite par frédéric un atelier peinture
collage d'animaux cris en objets de
récupération pour les plus jeunes et
surtout un déjeuner sur ma faim oui
surtout pour les amateurs de viande bien
sûr alors le menu donne l'eau à la
bouche
un barbecue sur le thème du boeuf à colt
est d'arriver d'art charcuterie une
pièce devons de viande pardon et surtout
si vous reste de l'appelation de
charlotte fait maison
un petit propre petite précision les
animations sont gratuites par contre
pour le repas il ya une participation
entre 17 et 25 euros qui est demandé et
vous pourrez aussi découvrir les
produits les acheter en détail surtout
échanger avec martin et frédéric cyr
leur travail mais c'est très très
important on a beaucoup de questions
lors de cette journée de 37 journées de
portes ouvertes sur notre métier comment
quand elle est de nos difficultés et
puis ça m'est été rude difficile
financièrement ce n'est pas un métier
très rémunérateur mais bon voilà c'est
un métier de passion plat vente lourd et
comme vous le disiez un peu plus tôt
camille d'autres fermes participent à
cette fête la ferme de loire au à son
chant qui propose là aussi des balades
de poney et à dos d'âne et une visite du
verger de pommiers et pourquoi pas des
déguster le pardon ce jus de pomme du
côté de senlis et la ferme de fans sur
sa boutique de 9h à 18h leurs produits
des escargots des terrines de gibier
des oeufs et des confitures et pour
terminer on va à la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet qui participent à cette
fête alors un petit déjeuner bio est
organisée de 9 heures à midi dans la
cour royale et vous pourrez aussi
déguster la mozzarella à la ferme
pédagogique
il y aura aussi une exposition sur le
travail de l'ifsi voilà une journée au
coeur de la ferme à la rencontre des
producteurs locaux et de leurs animaux
on le rappelle c'est dimanche peut-être
rejoindre 4 juin dans les fermes de la
vallée de chevreuse merci beaucoup mais
anip auquel nous avoir présenté les
différentes animations c'est là